[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of The Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I am delighted to welcome
you to today's lecture
by Nora Volkow entitled The
Sleep-Deprived Human Brain.
And hopefully we don't have too
many of those in the audience
today.
Here at Radcliffe we are
dedicated to fostering
and to sharing path breaking
work across disciplines.
And we do this by convening
leaning scholars, scientists,
and artists, and by
organizing a full calendar
of public programming,
including conferences,
lectures like the one you're
at today, and exhibitions.
Our program today is
part of the Davis Lecture
Series established
by Kim and Judy Davis
to bring leading
thinkers in all fields
to the Radcliffe Institute
to give public talks.
I'm very glad to see Kim
in the audience here today
and I am thrilled to have Nora
Volkow as our Davis lecturer
this afternoon.
Now it's very rare to find
Nora's formidable combination
of talents in a
single individual.
Nora is an intrepid
and prolific scientist,
having published over
600 journal articles.
But she is also a tireless
and compelling advocate.
Nora shares her research with
the public and the policymakers
helping to shape our national
debate on crucial health
issues in critical ways.
And as if that
weren't enough, Nora
is also a committed and
distinguished administrator,
having served since 2003
as Director of the National
Institute on Drug
Abuse, and before that,
in senior roles at the
Brookhaven National Laboratory.
Nora is renowned for her
pioneering use of brain imaging
to study the toxic effects and
addictive properties of drugs
of abuse.
Nora's research was instrumental
in showing that addiction
is a chronic disease of
the brain, an insight
with major implications both
for psychiatry and for policy.
This body of work has been
critical to identifying
the neurochemical
mechanisms of the brain that
play a role in
individual vulnerability
to substance use disorders.
It would be hard to
overstate the importance
of this research.
The brain disease
model of addiction
represented a fundamental change
from the previously widespread
view that substance
abuse disorders
reflect weak willpower
or moral failing.
Among the outcomes of
this paradigm shift
was the passage of the Mental
Health Parity and Addiction
Act of 2008, which required
health insurance providers
to offer the same types of
coverage for mental health,
including addiction, that they
provide for other diseases.
Nora's work has also been
central to our understanding
of the neurobiology of
obesity, of ADHD, and of aging.
In her lecture today Nora will
discuss brain imaging studies
in investigating the effects of
sleep deprivation highlighting
important links between
sleep, and addiction,
and other diseases.
Now the story of how Nora came
to do this kind of research
is unusual.
Nora grew up in Mexico
City in the house
where her great
grandfather, Leon Trotsky,
lived in exile until his
assassination in 1940.
After graduating at the top
of her class in medicine
at the National
University of Mexico,
Nora became fascinated by
a brain imaging technology
called positron emission
tomography, or PET for short.
So Nora traveled to New York
University School of Medicine
where researchers were doing
PET imaging in collaboration
with the Brookhaven
National Laboratory.
Nora was already impressive
by her mid-twenties,
and these scientists seized
the opportunity to hire her.
Nora then enrolled in NYU'S
residency program in psychiatry
and used PET imaging to study
brain tumors and schizophrenia.
She soon earned the
Laughlin Fellowship Award
from the American
College of Psychiatrists,
which is given annually
to outstanding psychiatric
residents deemed likely to
make a significant contribution
to the field.
Nora next joined the faculty of
the University of Texas Health
Science Center at
Houston intending
to continue her research
into schizophrenia.
When she discovered a shortage
of appropriate patients
at the University Hospital,
she had a novel idea
to use the same
imaging technique
to study patients admitted
for psychosis from having
taken cocaine.
This investigation led to
the breakthrough discovery
that cocaine, which was
generally considered safe
at the time, is in
fact toxic and damages
the brain by
decreasing blood flow.
Her findings went
so against the grain
that no science journal would
publish them for three years.
Nora's commitment to
gather data and follow them
where they ever they lead,
even when her results challenge
the public and
scientific consensus,
has remained the
keystone to what
makes her work so compelling.
After moving on to Brookhaven
National Laboratory
in the State University of
New York at Stony Brook,
Nora served in a number
of leadership roles
while continuing her ambitious
research program on addiction.
In her current
position as director
of the National
Institute on Drug Abuse,
Nora's advocacy for new
policies and treatments
based on sound science
has been vital.
But she is also an
inspiring model of someone
who effectively combines
scientific research,
institutional leadership,
and policy advocacy.
So now please join me in giving
a warm welcome to Nora Volkov.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thanks very much
that was very kind.
Good afternoon, everybody.
It's actually a
pleasure to be here.
I'm just sort of humbled by
the very nice introduction
and the point that
says, well I hope
that there are not many
people who are sleep-deprived
deprived here.
I sort of said I am one of them.
My life is very, very crazy.
It's very unusual for
me to come into a forum
right now amidst
the opiate crises
and speak of something that's
not specifically, directly
related to drugs.
And this is related
to drugs, because I
was basically was being told
almost everything that we
know about how the brain
works is negatively
influenced by drugs.
But this will dwell much more
into the process of sleep.
It reflects studies that we
have been doing in my laboratory
to try to address the
important question about why
is it that we sleep.
We spend at least 30% to
40% of our time sleeping.
During sleep we are
extraordinary vulnerable.
And yet despite this
vulnerability, biologically,
we cannot forego sleep, which
clearly highlights that it must
play an extraordinary,
fundamental role.
Why did I start to get
engaged with sleep?
I started to get involved
with sleep interested
in the concept of sleep in my
brain from two perspectives.
One of them, the
recognization that patients
that were basically
addicted to drugs
have very severe disruption
of the sleep patterns.
And that was something that was
very salient, and at that time
I was very much engaged
in studying cocaine.
Cocaine in animal
models produce something
that actually no other
drug can produce,
very few drugs can produce.
If you give an animal free
availability of the drug,
ultimately the only drug where
animals will forego sleep
is cocaine.
And as a result of
foregoing this sleep,
these animals will be
dead within three weeks
of free availability to drugs.
And it is recognized also
in animal experiments
that animals do not
survive sleep deprivation.
But to me it was very telling
in terms of how profoundly
a drug can remove the basic
instincts for survival,
that it could lead an animal
to stop sleeping in order
to get the drug.
And that was one of the
first things when I said,
well, there is
something in there.
The other aspect that I was
very intrigued about sleep about
will lead me to the
first part of my talk
which has two components.
One of the studies of sleep
that very specifically addresses
the question, does sleep
influence the brain dopamine
system?
The brain dopamine system
is the main mechanism
by which drugs are requiring.
All of the drugs that
produce addiction
activate the dopamine system.
And this activation ultimately
results, in those people
that take it regularly and that
have vulnerability, in changes
that produce addiction.
But it is that dopamine
that leads us there.
The dopamine system is what
assigns saliency to values,
to reinforcers.
It is what motivates our action.
And I've always been very
curious and intrigued
about why is it that in
general, drug taking behavior
tends to acquire much more
towards the end of the day.
Why do you see that most
people tend to actually binge
at that period of time?
And you could put up two
questions, two answers to that.
It says, well, it's social
systems that lead to it.
In the morning we work, and in
the evening we play and party.
But then if you're
more critical and say,
is this just an
aleatory phenomena?
I would say it's very unlikely
to be an aleatory phenomena.
It's likely to reflect the
biology of all of our circadian
rhythms.
So I became very intrigued
about the concept
of what happens to the
circadian variability,
to the differences in function
of our dopamine system
in the morning versus the
evening that could make drugs
more rewarding towards the end
of the day than in the morning.
That's what led me
to think of very
much of the first part of the
talk, which is the one related
to the dopamine system.
The second one is a new
space that we've gone in,
also extraordinarily
important, that
relates to the role
of sleep in basically
being able to detoxify our brain
from proteins and molecules
such beta amyloid that
are of course implicated
in Alzheimer's disease.
The first part of the
talk is our studies
that we have been doing
for many years now.
The last part of the talk is
new studies that have not yet
been published.
They are in press.
So we know that
sleep is fundamental
and we recognize it from
the perspective of all of us
that when we are
badly sleep deprived,
our cognitive
performance goes down.
And one of the processes that's
most disrupted, certainly
in my brain, is of memory.
So when I have to
fly abroad and I
have to give a talk in
a different language
it becomes very
awkward because I
am afraid that I will forget
the words when I'm speaking.
So it does interfere with
cognitive performance, sleep.
We also know that it
interferes with alertness.
And part of our impairments
in cognitive performance
may be that our alertness
and arousal goes down.
So we cannot sustain effort,
we cannot sustained attention.
And that is one of
the main mechanisms
that results in accidents.
If you look at it in terms of
the statistics of accidents
in the United States, as it
is the case in other areas
of the world too, there are
more people and more fatalities
associated with car
accidents leading
with sleep impairments and
improper sleep behavior
than they are with alcohol.
So it's as important as that.
We don't explain or
express it like that,
but it does play a
very significant role
in public health.
And the third element more
and more we're recognizing,
that impaired sleep
behavior is associated
with a variety of diseases,
including a much higher risk
of obesity.
This is very elegantly
studied and investigated
with respect to what are
the endocrine signals that
are changed by
sleep deprivation,
as well as studies
that now are starting
to emerge to show that impaired
sleep is also associated
with higher risk for dementia.
At the end of my talk
with present data
I will show you
our newest findings
with imaging in this respect.
So let's start with the brain
and the dopamine system.
What is the role of dopamine?
Is it recognized as important
to the sleep wake cycle?
And there has been a lot
of fire of controversy
in this space with some
saying, no, dopamine
is not important to
the sleep wake cycle.
And that tended to
be older literature.
As more sophisticated
technologies are emerging
it has become clear that the
dopamine system is fundamental
for arousal,
fundamental for arousal.
In fact, when you
have anesthesia
and you want to actually bring
someone out of the anesthesia,
one of the classical
drugs that you give
is a stimulant drug
that increases dopamine.
And if you want to awaken an
animal that is anesthetized,
you can specifically
stimulate the dopamine cells
and they arouse.
So this recognized that
the dopamine cells that
are located in the midbrain
ventral tegmental area,
and to a lesser extent
the substantia nigra,
are very important
in the arousal.
In the middle you see data that
has been shown and replicated
independently by
various laboratories.
When you measure
dopamine in the brain,
and actually also
when you measure it
in reward regions of the
brain that receive these very
strong, strong projections,
terminals of dopamine,
you see our
circadian variability
where the levels of dopamine
vary as a function of time.
Now for those of you that
are not very familiar
with rats in the laboratory,
rats, when it's dark
are very active.
That's when their dopamine
system is more activated
and as they become quiescent
in sleep, that's where
the dopamine system goes down.
So there is clear cut evidence
of this circadian variability.
And it's got to the point
that researchers now
have identified the
protein in the brain that
is responsible for the circadian
variability of dopamine.
That is a molecule that we
call dopamine transporter
whose function is to recycle.
It brings dopamine back
into the cell, removing it.
So when you don't have
that protein, which
is a very elegant way of
regulating how much dopamine
is outside, these animals lose
their circadian variability.
Then if you wanted
and you needed
more evidence of how important
the dopamine system is,
recognize that the most potent
medications that we have
to actually promote arousal to
keep people awake when they are
in conditions of
sleep deprivation,
such as for example,
pilots or soldiers that
have to perform under
tremendous amounts of stress
over 24 or 48 hours, those are
the stimulant drugs or drugs
like modafinil.
All of them increase dopamine.
And their arousing
effect is basically
mediated by their dopaminergic
actions, predominantly.
Also we all recognize
that in diseases
that affect the dopamine system,
the most notably recognized
is Parkinson's disease because
your dopamine cells get
damaged, you lose 90%
of the dopamine cells,
there is profound disruption
of the sleep wake cycle.
So in light of that we
said, OK all of these
are animal studies,
let's then study
the very specific question.
If indeed you are saying
that there may be,
in certain patterns
of social behavior,
that over all the
possibility people
may be more sensitive to
reinforcers like drugs
or like excessive
food consumption
towards the end of the day.
Also when people
are sleep deprived,
they are much less likely to
regulate their own desires
and much more likely to
engage in impulsive behaviors.
So we wanted to know, well,
how does that translate
from the perspective of
the signaling mechanism
in the human brain.
And we use positron
emission tomography,
which is an imaging technology
that allows us specifically
to look at targets
that are involved
in signaling between neurons.
In this case our target
was dopamine cells.
The way that we actually
can look at them
is by measuring
the concentration
of different proteins.
So one of them is that
dopamine transporter.
This is the protein that if
you remove it in animals,
you remove the
circadian variability.
So we know from
animal experiments.
This is a key protein in
regulating levels of dopamine.
We also focus on the
dopamine D2 receptor
because the D2
receptor's system is
one of there's some
main mechanisms that
signals activation,
that ultimately
may be responsible
for motivation
for reinforcement for arousal.
And we do know
that when you give
drugs that block the
dopamine D2 receptors,
you actually interfere
with arousal.
So this produces sedation.
So we decided to
do a study to ask
if we sleep deprive normal,
healthy people over one
night of sleep deprivation,
how much are there changes
in these molecules
that are the very
important ones in basically
modulating dopamine signaling.
So we studied subjects
in which we measured
dopamine transporters and we
measured dopamine D2 receptors,
under two very
different conditions,
after they have slept all night
and we monitor their sleep
to secure that they
were sleeping properly.
That was one condition.
And the condition
is we basically
had someone with
them all night long
to ensure that they were awake.
And we of course
regulated that so
that they were not taking any
substances that could directly
impact dopaminergic
signaling, such as in the case
of caffeine.
And then what did we observe?
So this is the design.
We did a positron
emission study.
And at the end they were
studied on two different days--
one after rested sleep--
the one after sleep
deprivation that's what we call
sd, and the other is
the rested wakefulness
after a good night's sleep.
We do the PET scans,
and then we do an MRI.
And an MRI is another
imaging technique,
different from PET which
looks at biochemistry,
that allows us to see how
the brain is activated.
That reactivity of the
neuronal systems in the brain.
So combining both of them gives
us a biochemical perspective
and a functional neuronal one.
So what did we observe in
terms of dopamine transporters?
So these are the average
images of all of the subjects
to measure the
peak concentration
of dopamine transporters
after rested wakefulness.
And you see that the
transporters are predominantly
located in the striatum.
This is the same subjects, the
average image for all of them
after sleep deprivation.
You can just actually
visually see basically
there no difference.
And when you quantify them,
this was very surprising.
I was expecting that
with sleep deprivation
you would actually
observe a decrease
in the dopamine transporters.
That's what I had predicted
because if you decrease
dopamine transporters
that would amplify
the dopaminergic
signal, and that
will help sustain arousal since
these subjects actually were
not allowed to fall asleep.
But we didn't observe that.
Now what about
dopamine D2 receptors?
They're what we all
observed was actually
a significant difference.
And I'll go into
what it basically
may mean with this technology.
So what you are
observing is that these
are the levels of
dopamine D2 receptors,
again in the same areas
because they are basically
continuous cells where
we measure transporters
and receptors.
Both of them, of course,
are located in the striatum.
This actually is the averaging
math for sleep deprivation.
When you quantified
whether it is
in the caudate or
the putamen, which
are parts of the
dorsal striatum,
you see a significant
reduction in the binding
of the ligand of
this compound that
binds to dopamine D2 receptors.
Which actually was very
interesting at that time.
And I hope I have a
slide to basically
explain to you more specifically
why we interpreted it that way.
But at that time the
way that we interpreted
it is that this ligand
binds to the receptors,
but it can only bind to those
receptors that are empty.
It's like when you
go to an auditorium
and you can only
sit on the chairs
when they are no one
is sitting there.
These ligand behaves
exactly like that.
So if there's a lot of
dopamine those receptors
are going to be
occupied by dopamine,
and then you will see a decrease
in the binding of the ligand.
And so this is a strategy
that a lot of researchers
are using to directly
measure different stimuli,
different drug
effects, and whether it
changes dopamine
concentration in the brain.
And we have been one of
the first laboratories
to use it that way.
In fact, we were the
first laboratory.
We interpret this to indicate
this decrease in the
dopamine D2 receptors
that we observed here.
We interpreted it state that
when people are sleep deprived
and they have to stay
awake the next day,
there is a compensation in
order to maintain alertness
that leads to increases
some dopamine.
That's the way that we actually
reported on that journal
and the science paper in 2008.
It was not completely
in my brain.
My brain was hurting.
I mean my brain hurts
me, I have to confess
to do all of these things.
It was hurting me because
we have consistently
been studying effects of the
stimulant drugs on alertness
and arousal, and we
have consistently
shown that the more you
increase dopamine the greater
the arousal.
So here I'm going
to show you what
we observe when
dopamine supposedly
was increased by
sleep deprivation
and it's relation to arousal.
We're observing
exactly the opposite.
So we had in the past said,
the more you change dopamine,
the less tired you are.
Here, what we are
observing, this
is the measure of
changes in dopamine.
Our interpretation is a decrease
in the binding of our ligand.
That basically the more you
change, the more tired you are.
It was completely
antithetical to everything
that we had ever reported,
and of course my brain
was hurting me.
I mean, you cannot have two
things in the same place,
there was no space.
And then what about cognition?
And this was very
important because when
we've done the studies on
stimulant medications that
increase arousal, we
also have observed
that the extent to which
they increase dopamine,
if you are sleep deprived,
they improve your arousal
and your cognitive performance.
One of the tests
that we have been
using for many, many
years, in many laboratories
is very standardized, is
a visual attention task.
Basically what you
are asked to do
is to pay attention initially
and it goes increasingly more
complicated, but you
start with a simple one.
I said, OK, pay attention
to these blue dots here
and these blue dots there.
And then the blue
dots start to move
and I asked you where they are.
So you have to focus attention
to basically remember where
they were located at the end.
Then you go into three of
them, and then four of them,
and then you can actually
monitor accuracy.
We were doing this all these in
these rested or sleep deprived
people while they're
were the magnet.
As you may imagine
these are the results
that correspond to the rested
verses the sleep deprivation.
And as you may very,
very much predict,
performance went down for the
sleep deprived because you
cannot sustain attention.
The harder it is, the task, the
worse the performance becomes.
So then we ask the
question, is this in any way
related to the changes in
dopamine that we observe?
And again, we had been
consistently observing
that the greater the
increases in dopamine,
the greater the improvement
of performance when you did it
as a stimulant medication.
And here we actually observe
exactly the opposite too.
That greater the changes
in the binding, the greater
the decreases in the
binding of the ligand,
we interpreted to actually
mean that there was increases
in dopamine that worsened the
performance in those two areas.
First of all, these
document that these changes
in the binding of the
ligand were important,
both for behavior as it relates
to the perception of arousal
and tiredness.
But they were also important
for cognitive performance.
When we go on and look
at the imaging studies
themselves with fMRI, we also
observe that indeed very much
the D2 receptor changes were
modulating their responses
on activation.
But I don't want to
go into that because I
don't want to not
to be able to get
into that last part of my talk.
So what we had
reported was there
you have this technique
that I was explaining.
This is the raclopride when
the receptors are empty,
it binds and you see
an image like this.
When dopamine is occupied,
basically raclopride cannot
bind and it goes down.
So that's when you
interpret it to suggest
there's a lot of dopamine
and it occupies the receptor.
And that has been the main
hypothesis interpretation.
But we did put, however,
we cannot actually rule out
the possibility that in sleep
deprivation decreases were due
to the fact that we have a
decrease a downregulation
of the levels of
dopamine D2 receptors.
- Now, why we did
not postulate these
as the main
interpretation, which
of course, when you look
at things retrospectively,
you say of course.
It's of course, because
it's actuallr-- it
was the relationship with
behavior and cognition
was opposite to everything
else that we've seen.
But the reason why I
say was not evident
is that as we look,
and we continue
to look at the modifications
of the signaling system
throughout the day,
or by drugs, we
tend to focus very much on
the effects of these stimuli
on the content of
the neurotransmitter.
And we don't dwell
very much on the fact
that the expression pattern of
these receptors in the membrane
are very dynamic.
And in fact, much more
that we tend to actually
identify as relevant, and
that is exactly why we mean,
what I think is
the main reason why
we observe the particular
decrease in sleep deprivation
of the binding of the ligand.
My brain is very obsessive.
And it was [? scaring ?]
me, so I said, OK,
let me try to disentangle
it because I couldn't--
I mean, this was something
I could not rule out.
So we designed a
second study in which
we said, let's try to
differentiate that--
if sleep deprivation is
either increasing dopamine
or down regulating
dopamine D2 receptors.
But how can you disentangle?
Because with these ligands, the
binding cannot differentiate
whether the receptors are
occupied or whether you have
less receptors.
So we basically took advantage
also of methodologies
that we had developed
for other purposes.
In our laboratory, we have
been extensively studying
methylphenidate.
And actually, some of this work
was very much inspired by work
that [? Bertha Madras ?] and
[INAUDIBLE] [? Cadon ?] here
in Boston working with another
dopamine transporter blocker,
which is cocaine.
And what is interesting
about both cocaine
and methylphenidate is that they
block the dopamine transporter,
and since this is the main
mechanism for recycling
dopamine that is liberated
from that terminal
back again, dopamine
accumulates, and that basically
amplifies the signal.
And hear me say it,
Cocaine and methylphenidate
are not stimulating it directly
the receptors.
They're basically amplifying
that our own dopaminergic
signaling, by interfering
with that recycling.
So we can use that
methodologically
as an experimental
strategy for past studies,
where we wanted to
actually document
whether with this methodology
we could see changes
in dopamine produced by salient
stimuli that were not drugs.
And so in 2002, for
example, we did a study
to try to determine if we could
see changes in raclopride when
we exposed people that
were food deprived
to visual stimuli of
very appealing food.
And we observed that--
And that's what we call salient,
that we observed that they were
basically what appeared
to be a decrease,
but this was not significant.
So in order to
amplify the effect,
we gave them methylphenidate,
and what you observe
is that methylphenidate
by itself
will decrease the binding,
but of course because it's
increasing dopamine,
or amplifying.
But when you combine
methylphenidate
with a salient stimuli, the
visual stimuli for someone
that is food deprived,
you can actually
observe a significant effect.
And this has been used also by
laboratory animal experiments,
and we've used it
in other settings
to actually use the
methylphenidate to amplify
the [INAUDIBLE] signaling.
So we then hypothesized
that if in fact, we
said if in sleep
deprivation, you
are increasing
dopamine release, then
if you give
methylphenidate, you should
be able to see an
amplified response,
because there's more dopamine
that's going to be released,
and this is going to be blocked.
So you should be able
to see a greater signal.
So we design,
again, an experiment
where subjects were brought
into the laboratory on two
different occasions.
One of them, we kept
them in the laboratory
and ensure that they sleep
properly, and on another day,
we brought them also
the night before,
and ensure that they
did not fall asleep.
The next day we test
them with raclopride
again, but this time twice,
first after a placebo
to see just the placebo effect,
and then 60 minutes later, we
gave them methylphenidate
and did another raclopride.
And with that, ask the question,
under those conditions,
are the increases
in dopamine produced
by methylphenidate larger
if you're sleep deprived?
Because you're amplifying
a greater signal or not.
What are the results?
Well, let me first go to what
is the behavioral effects
of methylphenidate
and sleep deprivation,
because they are actually
quite interesting by itself.
And again, we're seeing here
the measurements of sleepiness
or alertness, different types
for the rested waking state,
and this is placebo
and in blue is
methylphenidate different
times after the administration.
And again, I'll touch
bases on that, because this
is very consistent.
When you are rested, and you
are given methylphenidate,
it does not further
improve your alertness.
You're already pretty
alerts so you just basically
have a ceiling effect.
And also, if your
sleeping is very low,
methylphenidate doesn't do much.
However, if you give
methylphenidate to someone that
is sleep deprived,
you can clearly
see a significant effect it
basically improves alertness,
and it significantly
decreases sleepiness.
And this is, again, one
of the concepts that
has led to that description
of the effects of stimulant
medications, like
methylphenidate or amphetamine
of being state dependent.
Its effects are going to be
affected by the mental state
at which you are giving them.
But what about the
changes in dopamine?
So these are the results,
and I'm showing them here
in a different format in a
format where I'm identifying
in the color scale
here, the areas where
raclopride binding was
decreased by that intervention.
And again, our intervention
that we're comparing
is placebo versus
methylphenidate,
when you have slept very
nicely all night long,
and placebo versus
methylphenidate, when
you have been sleep deprived.
And here is when you have
been rested all night long,
and you see the changes in
all of the striatal areas.
And that's where
you see and this
is the magnitude of the
change in the model parameter
that we used to quantify the
specific binding of our ligand.
And this is where you have
it in sleep deprivation.
Just visually you cannot
see any difference,
and when you do statistical
tests to compare is there any
difference between the delta,
the changes in the restive
condition, versus the changes
proposed by methylphenidate
in the sleeping condition, none
of the effects are significant.
So we were unable to
see any differences
in the magnitude of
the changes in dopamine
as a function of
sleep deprivation,
and when we went
back and say OK,
how does that then relate
to the changes in behavior
that we had previously
observed, in the case of sleep
deprivation before, again we're
documenting this completely
different response and
relationship to that behavior,
as well as a cognitive
actions, depending
on whether you are evaluating
the changes with sleep
deprivation, versus when you are
evaluating the changes produced
by methylphenidate.
When you are evaluating
the changes produced
by sleep deprivation, that
larger the changes you produce,
that lower the alertness.
The larger the
changes you produce,
the higher the sleepiness.
In contrast, when you
give methylphenidate,
you are also dramatically
changing the raclopride
binding, but in this case
the higher that decrease
is in the raclopride binding,
the greater the alertness.
The higher that
decrease is in that
you have the raclopride binding,
the lower the sleepiness.
It's basically two
opposite patterns,
which indicated to us that
it is likely to be reflecting
different physiological
processes.
And that is ultimately the
way that we reported it.
Now this is our studies
that we're doing in humans,
and as I very explicitly state,
the design of the experiment
was to actually determine if
we could detect differences.
But we are always
have the constraint
of not being at the end of
the day, able to differentiate
directly with either
raclopride measure,
whether it is
changes on dopamine
or down regulation
of the receptors.
So in parallel to
the studies, we
conducted microdialysis
experiments in rats,
where you can actually
put microdialysis probe
into the striatal and monitor
the changes in dopamine.
And in these animals,
we had two groups,
and we follow exactly the
same experimental paradigm.
One group of animals was
sleep deprived, and the way
that you sleep deprive animals.
It's extremely difficult to
make animals forgo sleep.
So you have to put them in a
tiny little platform surrounded
by water, so that they
when they fall asleep,
they lose their reflexes,
and they actually immediately
wake up, because
otherwise they drown.
So that is the way
that you sleep deprive.
And the control
was the same setup,
but the platform
was much larger,
so if the animals lose their
reflexes from the sleep,
they can fall asleep, and then
we gave them methylphenidate,
and we monitor the
changes in dopamine.
And so we had the
controls in black.
They are black.
And we have the sleep
deprived animals in gray.
And these are the
changes in dopamine
when we gave the
methylphenidate injection.
And you can clearly see they
are basically identical.
We were unable to see any
significant differences
in the magnitude of the
changes of dopamine produced
by methylphenidate indicating
that under sleep deprivation
conditions, it does
not look that there
is an increase in
dopamine release.
And that is what
basically led us
to stay against that
traditional mode of thinking.
And again, this is not
That sleep deprivation
appears to down regulate
the number of dopamine
D2 receptors, the levels
of receptors, dopamine
D2 receptors that
are in your brain.
It decreases them.
Now how does it do that?
And that's where we are after.
It's a very intriguing,
extremely interesting question.
Is it just a normal process that
through circadian variability,
those receptors
are internalized?
Or is there an active
effect of sleep
deprivation on bringing
those receptors down?
And again, it's something
that we have a protocol.
I don't have data yet on that.
But from the animal literature,
where of course, you
can learn an enormous
amount, studies
have shown something that
also has obsessed me now
for many, many years.
When we are awake,
and the longer
we are awake, because our
neurons are very, very active.
We want them to be active.
You're actually
producing adenosine
as a function of
activation patterns.
And the longer you are
awake, the higher the content
of adenosine in your brain.
Adenosine then acts as
a neurotransmitter that
binds to adenosine receptors.
We have three different
types of adenosine receptors
in the brain.
The most notable are
adenosine A1 and adenosine A2.
Extraordinarily important for
multiple things, and by the way
caffeine, the one
that I know, basically
blocks those receptors
and interferes
with the effects of adenosine.
Adenosine in animal
models makes you sleepy.
And in animal models
where you can genetically
remove one specific receptor,
adenosine one versus two,
it has been shown
that it is that it
is the removal of
the adenosine A2
receptor that is responsible for
the waking effects of caffeine.
And what's interesting
about adenosine A2 receptors
is they are located exactly
in the same cells that
express dopamine D2 receptors.
Not only that,
these two receptors
form what we call
our [INAUDIBLE]..
They link with one another.
And as they link, they influence
the affects of one another.
When adenosine,
and this is again
[INAUDIBLE] in
animals, when adenosine
binds to this [INAUDIBLE],,
it binds to its adenosine A2
receptor.
That promotes the
internalization
of the receptor.
And this has been
reported in animals,
maybe one of the mechanisms by
which adenosine accumulation
may result in a down regulation
of dopamine D2 receptors.
But this is again theoretical,
and my brain likes ideas.
I mean, you come
up with an idea,
you come up with an
explanation, and it
just keeps on bothering
me and sort of says
how do you test these
hypothesis of the raclopride
that in fact, with
sleep deprivation,
you're actually down regulating
the levels of dopamine D2
receptors.
And if these literature
in animals is correct,
then it follows the big
question that we all have.
Why is caffeine
in general overall
quite effective in
improving alertness?
For many, many
years, investigators
were saying OK, caffeine
increases dopamine just
like other drugs of abuse.
Well, the literature
didn't really show that.
Most studies show that different
from cocaine, nicotine,
alcohol, marijuana, caffeine
does not increase dopamine
in the nucleus accumbens.
There was one paper by
[? Sergie ?] [? Fered ?] that
said, yes, maybe,
no, I don't know,
but consistently it
doesn't show that.
So then the question
is what does it do?
And so of course, my
brain was saying could it
be that it is actually
acting, caffeine
acts by interfering
with the down regulation
of that dopamine D2 receptors
with the sleep deprivation?
I said, OK let's do this study.
Let's try to test it.
So we perform a
study again using,
the C11 raclopride
but in this case,
instead of actually being
a, working with just two
people that were
rested wakefulness,
studied them with rock upright
with and without caffeine
and determine, well
why is it that caffeine
is going to be doing
to the availability
of those dopamine D2 receptors.
And what we observe,
which was actually
very different from anything--
Oh my god, this has jumped
or is my imagination.
Very different from
anything that we have ever
observed because when
we give methylphenidate,
we observe that it
increases dopamine,
and that's associated
with alertness.
When we gave caffeine,
what we observe
was not that like
with methylphenidate,
raclopride went down.
When we gave caffeine,
raclopride binding
went out throughout the dorsal
and the ventral striatal.
And you have here the
individual data for all.
It's quite significant.
So what we are
observing it is actually
very likely that caffeine
is improving arousal,
is not increasing dopamine,
because otherwise we
would have observed a decrease
in the binding of the ligand.
But on the other
hand, it seems to be
interfering with that down
regulation of the dopamine D2
receptors.
Now with science, I think that
one of the interesting things
that I've learned
with science is
that I feel very strongly
that this is the explanation.
But at the same time,
my brain, which never
stops saying well what about.
I think that there is
another what about,
which is the possibility that,
when you form these [INAUDIBLE]
and you stimulate it, you
may not just internalize
that receptor, but
you also appear
to maybe affecting the binding
affinity of that receptor.
So we cannot completely rule out
the possibility that it's not
just interfering with that down
regulation of the receptors,
but also it may increased the
affinity of the D2 receptors
for raclopride.
I don't think that's
the explanation,
but I have to basically
put it forward.
Because there are
some that think
that this may be the case.
And so throughout
all of these studies
that we have been doing
within the whole process
of understanding
the effects of sleep
in the dopaminergic system,
what we've come to realize
is that sleep deprivation
has a very profound effect
in down regulating levels
of dopamine D2 receptors.
And for those in the
substance abuse field,
this is fundamental, because one
of the most consistent findings
that we observe in addiction
is that down regulation
of those dopamine D2 receptors.
And in all animal models that
have been developed, whether it
is cocaine, alcohol, or
heroin, or even nicotine,
any intervention that
you do to decrease
the levels of
dopamine D2 receptors
makes those animals
much more vulnerable
for the rewarding
effects of the drugs.
It makes them much
more vulnerable
for impulsive behaviors.
And it makes them much more
vulnerable to compulsiveness.
And again, highlighting that
intricate involvement of sleep
and its disruption
in addiction as part
of a fundamental component of
the pathology of addiction.
And this data, of course,
is forcing us into looking
backward now into our
own resource and trying
to determine the extent
to which we have in many,
many independent studies,
in animals and in humans,
and so have others, consistently
documented that in addiction,
there is a down regulation
of the dopamine D2 receptors,
which we know, you can produce
in animals by giving them
repeatedly the drug, but what
we cannot rule out is that some
of those effects of down
regulation may be also driven
by the profound disruption
on sleep patterns in these
individuals.
And again,
highlighting about why
focus on this area of
research is something
that we need to do
because it may also
be very relevant in
helping us design better
therapeutic interventions.
But I don't want to
dwell anymore on this,
and I want to go into the next
set of stories that we've done.
Again, we haven't
published this data.
It is now in press.
But it is something that
has started to obsess me
four years ago, and it
was motivated actually
by this paper that was published
by [? Niedergarde, ?] I think
it was 2014.
This cartoon came
later, in which
they actually, this
investigator from Denmark
reported that what appeared
to be a new understanding
about the role of sleep.
And the brain, what's
intriguing about the brain,
among many other things that
are intriguing about the brain
is that it doesn't have
a lymphatic system.
Every single organ in our
body has a lymphatic system,
and it's a very important
system of blood vessels,
not blood vessels of
vessels, lymphatic vessels.
What am I saying blood, they
are going to get offended.
Lymphatic vessels that
allow you to get rid
of toxic substances that
are very, very important
for proper immune function.
The brain doesn't have that.
And this has of course
intrigued enormously research,
because this is--
we have the brain is the most
energetically demanding organ.
So how is it getting rid
of all of those waste
material, toxic products?
So this paper for
[? Nedergaard ?]
documented a mechanism
by which they actually
are proposing that the brain
gets rid of some of these waste
problems.
And they determined
that glymphatic system,
lymphatic from the
lymphatic, but glymph,
because it's related
to glial cells.
And what they
showed in rodents is
that during sleep or also
produce during anesthesia,
basically what happens is
that the space that surrounds
arteries is full of
cerebrospinal fluid,
and during sleep, cerebral
spinal fluid passes
from this very vascular space
into the interstitial space
in the brain through the glial,
which is facilitated and made
possible by the expression of
these transporters of water
that we refer to as aquaporins,
and specifically aquaporin
four, which is express on the
glial cells that basically
surround these blood vessels.
And this allows for
cerebrospinal fluid
to go into the interstitial
space, and through convection,
flow, remove these
toxic materials that
end up back into the
perivascular space of veins,
and that ultimately drains
into the lymphatic system.
And they also
pointed out something
that was to me also
incredibly intriguing.
Using optical imaging, they
were able to document the fact
that when you are
asleep or in anesthesia,
that interstitial space, the
space outside of the cells,
is increased by 40% to
60%, as if the cells
themselves become smaller,
allowing for the extracellular
space to grow.
And that facilitates the
flow of cerebral spinal
flowing and the clearance.
And this completely
obsessed my mind.
I couldn't stop
thinking about it.
And I said oh my god
this is fascinating.
It's fascinating.
And it was an
interesting phenomenon,
because I said, how do we
demonstrate this in humans,
because no one has
shown this in humans.
Was there any data to indicate
that something was out there?
We knew from studies that
have been done actually
in animals and humans
that the clearance of some
of these waste products, and
in particular a lot of work
has been done on beta
amyloid, because beta amyloid
is the precursor that
actually results in plaques.
The amyloid plaques that
are basically responsible,
believed to be responsible
for Alzheimer's dementia.
And it had been shown as for
some of these studies that
I'm looking at these, that
indeed when you, for example,
sleep deprive animals, and this
is a fantastic study that was
published in 2009 in science,
and in this study that was done
in mice, they actually
demonstrate not only that
acute, but also chronic
sleep disturbances,
disruption in these mice,
significantly increases
the content of beta amyloid .
In this case, that we're
looking at the hippocampus.
Very much, if you get
the animals to sleep,
you basically can
clear that beta amyloid
that occurs with a single
night of sleep deprivation.
This is the data with
chronic sleep deprivation.
Human studies have looked at
the cerebral spinal fluid,
and then you can actually
measure the content of beta
amyloid, and in these studies,
they have also shown that
if you take a person-- this is
a study in 2014 at the same time
that the paper for
[? Nedergaard ?] came up
in science, that if you take
a person and you sleep deprive
them, you can actually--
Or even not sleep deprive them.
If I measure your
cerebral spinal fluid,
I can do a lumbar puncture here,
extract cerebral spinal fluid,
and I measure your
beta amyloid content,
say at 6:00 PM,
7:00 PM, and then
I measure it in the
morning say at 9:00,
10:00 AM, the content of
the cerebral spinal fluid
is going to be six percent
lower in the morning than
in the evening.
Again, consistent with the
concept that during sleep, you
are clearing the beta
amyloid, and that
leads to then a lower reduction
in the content of CSF.
And also a series
of imaging studies
have been done retrospectively,
using PET ligands that
are used predominantly for
the diagnosis of Alzheimer's
disease, on the basis that
these PET ligands bind
to beta amyloid.
So you can use them
to actually quantify
amyloid burden in the brain.
And of course, in
Alzheimer's disease,
you see a significant increase.
But if you take normal healthy
people of different ages,
studies predominantly done
in an elderly population
of healthy individuals has shown
that those individuals that
have inadequate sleep
patterns tended to have
higher content of beta amyloid.
And again, there is now I think
four of these studies that
have been able to replicate
it retrospectively to indicate
to us that in animals, yes,
one night of sleep deprivation
did raise beta amyloid in
the brain of these mice
in the hippocampus.
It was something like 16 or 20%.
It was a fairly large effect.
In the cerebral spinal
fluid, the effect of
sleep of decreasing
it by six percent.
And this thought
then occurred to me,
and I was drinking
a glass of wine.
I wasn't drinking coffee.
I was drinking a
glass of wine, and I
was in one of my exuberant
moods, and I said aha,
now I know how to test it.
I said in my brain,
I said, of course,
if the glymphatic system
operates in the human brain,
then it would follow that if
I take advantage of these PET
ligands that are being used to
measure beta amyloid in brain,
I should be able to document
that if I sleep deprive someone
just like the animal
experiments have shown,
I should be able to see an
increase of beta amyloid
in the human brain.
And I was very excited,
and said oh, I have
a great idea blah, blah, blah.
And I started then of course,
you do the literature search.
You speak with the
experts that have
developed these [INAUDIBLE].
And I said, Nora, it
is not going to work,
because the beta
amyloid PET ligands are
binding to insoluble
fiber, insoluble one.
That's plaque.
And so I gave the idea.
I was very depressed, and so
this 10 months, 12 months.
And then I started to go
back to the literature
and actually look
at the studies that
have looked at
people prospectively,
and something started to
bother me, started to bother me
because there was not
perfect reproducibility.
And it's not that if you were
study six months apart or one
year apart, you always saw
an increase in the binding
of these ligands.
In some instances, they
were going down, and I said,
could it be that they
are not as insoluble
as everybody is saying?
And sometimes, you just
have to bite the bullet,
and say I'm going
to take a risk.
I said, OK.
I'm going to take the risk.
We put the protocol, and
through the IRB got approved,
and we finally
finished the study.
And I'm going to
show you the results.
So our hypothesis were two.
One of them is we use the
PET ligand, florbetaben,
which is one that
you can actually,
if you don't have a cyclotron
and the fancy laboratory,
you can actually order it
because it's used clinically
for diagnosing patients
with Alzheimer's disease.
And so we said, we're going
to do a study which we're
going to measure florbetaben
binding in the human brain
under two conditions,
rested sleep
versus 24 hours of sleep
deprivation, all night sleep
deprivation, and see if
we're increasing the binding.
And because the animal studies
had seen the largest effects,
we apriori predicted
that on the basis of what
we know from animal studies
that increases should be greater
in the hippocampus, and
also the hippocampus
is the area of the brain, one
of the most sensitive areas
of pathology of
Alzheimer's disease.
But we also wanted to see
if in our sample, which
was of younger individuals,
we could replicate
the prior findings that if
you have impaired sleep,
chronic impaired
patterns of sleep,
that will be associated
under baseline,
no sleep deprivation, just
baseline condition, higher
levels of beta amyloid.
And so we recruited 20
healthy participants.
Each of them tested twice.
After more or less 31
hours of sleep deprivation,
which again, we bring them
to the clinical center,
ensure that they sleep properly.
We have polysomnography to
be sure that they are asleep.
We wake them up in the morning
at the same time of the day,
and we do the florbetaben scan.
We also measure their genes for
genotyping them for the APOE
genotype, because there's clear
data in [INAUDIBLE] controls
and in Alzheimer's patients,
that that genotype risk that
confers greater
vulnerability for Alzheimer's
also associated with a greater
vulnerability for accumulation
of beta amyloid in
the human brain,
particularly in
older individuals.
And of course we monitor, we
record the patterns of sleep
and the effects of sleep
deprivation on their alertness
and mood.
The one what we observe, and
these are the data, is actually
speaks for itself,
and Dr. [INAUDIBLE],,
a fellow in my
laboratory was the one
that actually did these
very elegant analyses
and deserves all of the credit
for having develops over
such a sophisticated
pattern of analysis.
And what he showed applying
a [INAUDIBLE] wide analysis
to the whole brain to try to
determine where there were
changes between
rested versus sleep
deprivation on the
accumulation of these ligand
that binds to beta amyloid,
which showed basically
there were significant
increases in this cluster
of area of subcortical regions
that actually part of it
is encompassed within
the hippocampus.
Not just in the
hippocampus, we also
see accumulation in the thalamus
and parahippocampal areas.
Basically, I asked,
Ehsan, and I said Ehsan,
we're seeing it is
significant, and this
is significant of [INAUDIBLE]
for multiple comparisons,
but is it significant, is it
driven by a couple of subjects,
or how consistent
is this findings?
So then he extracted
regions in the hippocampus,
and for each one
of them monitored
the values of the beta
amyloid PET ligand,
at rested versus
sleep deprivation.
And you can basically
see consistently
for almost all
subjects there was
an increase in the binding
of the beta amyloid,
and this is one night
of sleep deprivation.
And of course,
there was a couple
of people, where
you didn't see it,
but basically
consistently varies.
That's why it's so significant.
And interestingly, in
the hippocampus that
changes the accumulation of
the beta amyloid with the sleep
deprivation,
[INAUDIBLE] hippocampus
was not associated
with sleepiness,
or decreased alertness,
or tiredness.
It was associated with
a decrease in mood.
The greater the accumulation
of these beta amyloid
in the hippocampus, the
more irritable and dysphoric
the subjects felt.
Something that I did not, and
we did not apriori expect,
and I'm putting it forward,
because we did observe,
was that it was only
significant in the right,
but not in the left hippocampus.
I can give you an
explanation about why
that could be plausible, but
we didn't apriori propose that.
That was an unexpected finding.
Now what about the effects,
not on sleep deprivation,
but the scans where
you are actually
at baseline for the
accumulation of beta amyloid
in the brain versus the hours of
sleep reported by the subjects.
And what we observe
here, as well as
what are the effects of the
genetic risk based on the APOE
polymorphism, there
are two polymorphisms
there have been widely
investigated and associated
with that risk.
So you can put weight on
those two polymorphisms
and based on that,
determine how do
they influence the
accumulation of beta amyloid?
And this actually
summarizes the findings.
So these are the
areas in red where
there is an association
between higher
levels of beta amyloid binding
ligand, and less hours of sleep
reported by the subjects.
So subjects that had
lower amounts of sleep
had higher accumulation
are beta amyloid,
in this area of the brain that
is called the precuneus, that
is very important,
extraordinarily
important for alertness.
[INAUDIBLE] one of the areas
that is probably actually,
is not the area that shows
that's the first evidence
of dysfunction in
Alzheimer's disease.
It's an area that's constantly
active all the time.
It's basically one of the
main hubs of the brain,
and that's where you see
a higher accumulation.
You also see higher accumulation
in areas of the hippocampus,
and it's not exactly
the same region.
There's some overlap with the
areas that we observe in acute
sleep deprivation, but you
cannot say it's the same,
they are distinct areas.
This pattern is
much more widespread
than what we observe with
acute sleep deprivation.
And it's also clearly
distinct for the pattern
that we observe an
association between the gene,
risk allele, and
the accumulation
of beta amyloid, which
tends to involve much more
prefrontal cortical areas.
And this just shows
that a shorter
the amount of sleep
hours that you reported,
the greater the accumulation.
So what is it that we
conclude from this, that we
conclude for the first time.
And I think that is something
that cannot be ignored.
One single night of
sleep deprivation
produces significant
increase on beta
amyloid in the human brain.
Now, certainly,
what I would predict
that these would be the
follow up by experiment,
is that I predict that if you
allow these individuals to fall
asleep, you will be able
to clear the beta amyloid.
In other words, it is not
irreversible harmful effect.
That question emerges if you
chronically are sleep deprived,
is there a point that
constant accumulation
of the beta amyloid
starts to harm your brain?
And I think that
is the issue that
is most relevant as it
relates to prevention
messages towards prevention
of Alzheimer's disease
and dementia.
The importance of healthy
sleep habits in order
to preclude the accumulation
of beta amyloid.
And I'm standing here
four years later,
when I basically was in
one of my flamboyant moods,
trying to figure out if we could
figure out a way of imaging
that glymphatic system.
I cannot say that this reflects
We postulate that the
accumulation is due to the fact
that that glymphatic system may
have not worked because they
were sleep deprived.
But from animal experiments,
we cannot neither rule
the possibility that there are
other mechanisms by which beta
amyloid is clear, number one,
and the other very important
factor is that when
you are sleep deprived,
you also have greater production
of neuronal toxic material,
so that may have led to
a greater accumulation.
And we cannot
differentiate that.
So we are still going
on, trying to figure out
a measure, an emerging
methodology, that
will allow us and enable us to
unequivocally say, yes, this
is evidence that there
is glymphatic function
in the human brain.
But what I can tell
you from these studies
is this is clear evidence that
sleep plays an extraordinarily
important role, not
just on regulating
dopaminergic signaling, and that
driving motivation and reward.
And we enforcement
but also very,
very importantly, in terms
of the capacity of the brain
to clear and renew itself after
a period of continued arousal,
and highlighting, again
why in many perspectives,
sleep has been a major
neglected subject of research,
but also major neglected aspect
of clinical interventions
or behavioral interventions
that could result in very
profound salutary effects.
And with that, I do want to
thank, this is my group at NIH
and our imaging
group, who actually
were very, very creative
and does all of the work.
This is Ehsan Shokri that
did all of the analyses.
We have been colleagues in
Brookhaven National Laboratory.
He's fantastic.
He can get things done that
nobody else in the world can,
and he has the capacity of
managing extraordinarily
difficult things.
He's a nuclear
medicine physician.
Dardo Tomasi is the physicist
of our group, and a lot of this
is related to instrumentation.
Sunny Kim is our
radio chemist, also
can label things
that nobody can.
And Baris Sukru, who's actually
from [INAUDIBLE] Turkish.
And he also is a physicist.
Ehsan is a bioengineering.
Corinde Wiers,
which is phenomenal.
She's just a dynamo, and
she's a neuropsychologist.
And this is our
extraordinary nurse
that comes in the middle
of the night to ensure
that people are staying awake.
And this is Peter Manza,
our newest post doc,
and just keep an eye on
them because they are really
extraordinary stars, and you
will be hearing more and more
on them.
So I'm very, very lucky to
have such a fantastic team,
and I want to thank you
all for your attention.
- What a wonderful talk.
My name is Bob Tockgold.
I'm director of the Center
for Sleep and Cognition
at Harvard Med, and I just
am so delighted that you're
working to increase
awareness and knowledge
about sleep and sleep
deprivation, try
to get us past
that point of view
that sleep is just
to cure sleepiness.
But I had a couple of
questions, which I wrote down,
so I'd remember.
So our D2 receptors go down
with sleep deprivation.
And then you take caffeine,
and that stops it, right?
You do this.
I don't drink coffee.
But you get a cup of
coffee, and in a half hour,
you feel better,
and in a half hour,
you're not having any effect
on that internalization
rate, right?
- Well to me, the
effects of caffeine last
like eight or 10 hours.
So as a result of that,
as much as I love coffee,
I cannot drink anything
after 10:00 AM.
In fact, sometimes if I
drink a lot of coffee,
it interferes with my
sleep during the night.
I wake up very, very early.
So I don't know that it is--
I mean, certainly
such a short effect.
I think that nobody has
studied, and it's likely
that there's
tremendous variability
because there are people to whom
caffeine doesn't do anything.
And the duration of
those effects also vary.
And as you know, the other
aspect that is very relevant
is you become tolerant to
the effects of caffeine
very rapidly.
And so the question when
you are discussing it,
you become tolerant to it,
what does it really mean?
Do you actually interfere
with the formation
of those [INAUDIBLE],, so
that you no longer can
interfere with the [INAUDIBLE]?
It hasn't been studied.
Because we just
did one time point,
and I cannot tell you
how long it would be.
It would be actually
very intriguing
to look at how long it
takes to get back to that.
No one has looked at that.
There is a group in Europe
that actually also show
exactly the same thing,
adenosine caffeine,
bringing up those
receptors, both like us,
they didn't follow it up
to see how long that lasts.
- Thank you.
And then the second
question I just
have to ask you is [INAUDIBLE]
stimulation and glial affects
the relationship to Alzheimer.
Do you know this story?
- I'm sorry.
I didn't catch that question.
- Sorry.
There's data now that if you do
40 Hertz transcranial electric,
that you can affect
the levels of A beta?
- There is an enormous
amount of interest of course
to try to use different
strategies to on the one hand
get rid of beta amyloid, and
then the other one to stimulate
neuronal systems, so
that, because that's
another proactive, protective
effect towards dementia.
Another one is to improve
blood vessels and circulation
to also help it.
So all of these are
interesting strategies.
As of now, the evidence
has not been strong enough
to say this is something
that we should move forward
that will get an indication.
What I would move
forward, though,
based on these data and
the data from others,
is that probably one of the
most important prevention
interventions that you can
do against Alzheimer's is
to try to ensure that
you sleep properly.
- Thank you.
- Hi, my name's Scott
[? Becket. ?] I'm
a registered polysonographic
graphic technician
at the Brigham Young
Women's Hospital Division
of Sleep Medicine.
And I also have done a
lot of volunteer work
with alcoholics and addicts
over the past five years.
And I think that your studies
on the reward system of drugs
of abuse is
interesting, but it just
brought out the
first question, which
is why is it then that when
people are removed from drugs
for an extremely long period
of time, decades even,
they'll still want to
go back to those drugs
and be addicted to them just
as bad as they were decades
before?
- That element which is
basically called conditioning
has been widely investigated
very elegantly in animals, also
in humans, but in
animals you can actually
be able to discern which
are the proteins that
are responsible for these
long lasting effects,
and this entails when
you stimulate with drugs
or any stimulation
that is very powerful,
you actually create an
activation of the D1 receptor
system that creates a memory.
And the way that that
memory is created basically
strengthens the connectivity
between synapses,
and the synapses that
have been most studied
where this is strengthened
is glutamatergic excitatory
synapses.
And that strengthening
involves on the one hand,
expression of different
type of receptors,
and degradation of others.
So you change the composition
of those receptors,
and the complexity of
those synapses also
morphologically changes.
And that is quite long lasting.
So those phenomena
persist way after you've
stopped taking the
drug, and by themselves,
when you get exposed to
an environment where you,
in the past or an
emotion that in the past
had led you to
associate with drugs,
immediately create a memory.
So you stimulate
the system, and that
foregoes the frontal cortex.
It's like when you touch
something that is hot
that you immediately remove it.
It's an automatic response.
That's one of the most
challenging aspects
that we see in addiction
that you have these modified
learning pathways
that can trigger
the behavior on
the conditions that
emulate the prior experiences.
And because a lot of people that
are taking drugs cannot control
necessarily when they are
going to be exposed to a very
stressful environment, that
puts them at a tremendous amount
of risk of relapse, or
they cannot really escape
their environments.
So that initially is
mediated by dopamine,
but it is consolidated by
glutamatergic system as well
as other neurotransmitters.
- Well, that actually leads
me to my second question.
You were talking about how
they can control their exposure
to stressful environments.
And I found your second
topic on the beta amyloid
and the glymphatic
system, I thought
you were going to
tie them together,
because in my experience
with alcoholics and addicts,
there's a lot of caffeine
abuse, nicotine abuse, long term
poor sleep hygiene, and kind
of destructive behaviors,
even without drugs.
They persist long
into their life,
even after they've
been sober for years.
Could that long term
poor sleep hygiene
and all these other things
I just described lead
to some sort of build up of
beta amyloid chronically, which
causes a chronic decrement in
mood and then leads to relapse?
- And that same question has
started to emerge in my brain.
I mean, and if you
look at the literature,
though, there's
very little there.
There is an association
of higher risk of dementia
with alcohol, but if you
look at the carefully,
the problem with all of
these studies on drugs
is these drugs are profoundly
damage blood vessels.
And it depends on which one,
and certainly for example,
in the case of the
stimulant drugs
like methamphetamine or
cocaine or even cannabis,
and that they also have
inflammatory processes.
So you could be producing
cognitive damage and dementia
through this
vascular phenomenon.
You could also, by
disrupting sleep,
put them at greater
risk of accumulation,
but it hasn't really
been studied at all.
And I do think it's
an important question.
Because I don't have
any data, I don't
feel in any way to say I mean
this could be a risk factor.
I think that we need to
conceive that it could be,
because it is having
multiple effects that
are harmful to the brain,
including sleep disruption,
but also markedly damaging
perfusion into the brain, which
is another factor that increases
your risk for dementia.
- I just want to clarify.
I wasn't talking about the
build up of beta amyloid
from long term drug use.
I was talking about
when they were
off of the drugs in question
for a long period of time,
they continued to with
unhealthy sleep behaviors,
and that led to the build up.
- I follow.
I do, but the bottom line is
we don't have any studies that
have looked at it.
- Thank you.
I'm just wondering
whether or not
sleep deprivation with
psycho simulations,
such as cocaine,
amphetamines, would give rise
to theoretically a higher level
of accumulation of beta amyloid
compared to other
addictive drugs,
such as benzodiazepines
or even heroin,
which are more sedating, as
well as partially euphoriant?
- [INAUDIBLE],, which
can also be sedating.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I think it is an
interesting question,
and you know, and again,
one of the concepts
that I was in my flamboyant
mood, I was sort of basically,
this happened at
an ACMP meeting.
that's why I was
drinking a glass of wine.
I remember very clearly.
It's interesting
how you remember
certain moments, when I
thought about this experiment.
And then I said,
well, ha, ha, what
we should do for
the helping treat
patients with
Alzheimer's dementia
is we put them in a coma.
We put them to sleep
for five days, right?
Let them clear their brain.
And I was saying it of course
under alcohol intoxication,
because one glass
will do it for me.
But I think that
this is actually,
I do think it is
a valid concept,
and if we understand it
better, could we then
actually design
interventions, and again
you have to be cautious,
because if you put someone
on anesthesia to try to,
because in the animals, they
lymphatic system
works with anesthesia.
But we also know that
anesthetics themselves may have
cognitively impairing effects.
So we need to understand
what are the drugs,
and there are multiple
process and darkness
that we don't really know
very well before we come up
with an intervention.
- Hi.
I was noticing that when you
talked about sleep deprivation,
and being able to
clear the brain,
you were basing it on
number of hours of sleep.
And I was wondering
what work had been done,
looking at sleep
apnea and its effect.
- Yeah, no, and I think
that there would be data.
Sleep apnea is one of the
factors that puts you--
It's considered, I think,
it's one of the factors that
is consider at put you at
higher risk of dementia,
but I mean this is the first--
The stories that have reported
on chronic sleep restriction,
the first one was the
group in Baltimore
the premier program at
the Aging Institute,
which was something
like three years ago,
have been done on prospective
studies that are following
these individuals.
But no one that I
know, not on the paper
that certainly that
has specifically
studied that severity
of the sleep apnea
under those conditions with
respect to the beta amyloid.
But I'm going to check and do a
Pub Med, because there may be,
and I just don't know.
- Good morning somewhere.
I have two questions.
My first is a yes/no question.
Is there any data
that meditation
may provide a
close approximation
to sleep when it comes to
detoxification of the brain?
I know the glymphatic
model is relatively new,
but that's just
my first question.
- No data.
- OK.
- You said yes/no.
No data.
Two words.
- Number two, so I guess there's
been 30 or 40 years in Europe
with the clinical
use of racetams
to address age associated
memory impairment
and neurodegeneration.
I'm wondering what
your take is on that.
Although it is certainly not
an FDA approved approach.
- Yeah, I mean this is
one of the mechanism,
and we do know that the
cholinergic system is also
extraordinarily
important in sustaining
sleep and arousal, and one of
the diagrams that I have there,
you have the
monoaminergic system,
and then you have the
cholinergic system.
And they do regulate, and they
basically modulate alertness,
but they also modulate memory.
So the extent to which we
can try to explain everything
under one particular model,
I think it's very simplistic,
and I would be surprised
if there are not
other interventions.
And again, I haven't
spoken either
about the adrenergic
system, which
is also very important
for giving you
a sense of overall alertness.
So we identified in
this very specific case
the role of sleep
deprivation and sleep
as it relates to the
clearance of beta amyloid.
We know that
noradrenergic system
is crucial for enabling sleep.
So if you stimulate
the local [INAUDIBLE],,
those animals are
not going to sleep.
And in fact, one of the
anesthetic agents they use,
the [INAUDIBLE],, is
basically interfering--
it's one of its
mechanism of action
is it blocks
noradrenergic signaling,
and it actually promotes very
nicely that lymphatic system.
And you can interfere
with some of these effects
by blocking the
adrenergic receptors.
And I'm just bringing it up
because the cholinergic system,
the [INAUDIBLE] system,
which is highly loaded
in the thalamus and other very
important alerting systems.
So I don't want in
any way to just say
this explains all this,
this explains clearly.
It documents that
sleep deprivation
can lead to beta amyloid
accumulation, which basically
in my brain, suggests that
one of the roles of sleep
is clearance.
It also shows from
our first studies
that another role of sleep
is to basically modulate,
in this case, dopaminergic
neurotransmission
throughout the day,
to ensure that there's
an optimal range of activity.
So those are two things
that we've demonstrated,
but I would be surprised that
there's not many more things
to discover in the sleep space.
- Please join me in thanking Dr.
Volkow for a wonderful lecture.
Now, I know you can't wait
to go home and go to sleep.